it's Father's Day so what better day to
bring you the sweet story of the couple
we've followed through their pandemic
pregnancy Carina and Elias are now
parents baby Anderson is their first he
was born about a month ago he's healthy
and well though his path into the world
did take a few turns babies don't care
about a global health crisis or worry if
it's the right time here's the new
reality of delivery in a pandemic I'm
Eli I'm Korean and he is Anderson and
this is our co vid birth story on Sunday
about a week after our due date I woke
up at 2:00 a.m. because my contractions
were getting much stronger so I started
tracking them and they were about five
minutes apart so the app was telling us
to go to the hospital but we've heard
not to do that so we just called our
doula and she came by the next morning
to check in because of kobane we wanted
to stay home as long as possible
originally the plan was to have a
natural birth at the hospital but we
were also prepared to have the baby at
home if things were going smoothly
contractions were intense and consistent
from Sunday through Tuesday the longest
being six or seven minutes apart and the
shortest being one and a half we're
talking three days of contractions
Korean soldier Don throughout with the
support of our doula and regular
check-ins from the midwives labor was
progressing slowly but they warned us
things could escalate at any time I
guess I just I'm just
yeah by Tuesday morning Kareem was
dilated 4 to 5 centimeters and the
Midwife suggested a castor oil cocktail
to try and speed things up naturally
parsnip cream took it twice but nothing
apparently she's impervious honestly she
was a champ through this whole thing
it's like interval training and we tried
everything so many different exercises
and listened to so much hypnobirthing
my blood pressure is always perfect and
stable on Tuesday night her water broke
but the dilation was about the same and
the baby wasn't in a great position on
the advice of our midwife we decided it
was time to head to the hospital for
some help 247 K xx xx xx baby's new
birthday we arrived checked in and
answer the Kovac questions I took the
long walk the labor delivery floor so
later Wednesday morning things hadn't
really progressed and the baby was in an
awkward position his head was facing up
into the right they call these babies
stargazers which is a cute name but not
good for delivery No
so around noon we made the call to move
ahead with a c-section we also didn't
want to risk Crean getting a fever
because then that unlocks all these
covert protocols which could involve
isolation and all these other tests and
ain't nobody got time to that they
prepped green for surgery coming back to
this with the baby I suited up and by
2:00 p.m. we were headed to do our with
the help of the exceptional team at the
BC Women's Hospital we welcomed a
beautiful little boy
oh it's a boy it's a boy the two days we
spent at the hospital in recovery were
really positive in part because of
coulded you got our own room because of
social distancing and with no visitors
allowed we had lots of time together to
hunker down just the three of us with
nurses close by should we have any
questions one nurse even mentioned an
increase in successful breastfeeding
during kovat because of the lack of
interruptions but we were ready to come
home your home since then Anderson has
been pretty great for the most part we
love his smiles and not startle reflex I
love watching him stare at himself in
the mirror and the face he makes when I
hit it with the hairdryer I love the way
he looks at us and the way Kareem looks
at him as she serenades him to sleep but
it's not all rainbows and lollipops
sometimes he's just fussy and he won't
stop crying
it's kind of like battling an internet
troll you see there's no reasoning with
them because facts don't matter
also we're sleeping less and then he'll
just be on you with Co bed one of the
hardest things is that there isn't
somebody else to hand him off to it's
just the two of us yeah I mean he's one
month old and besides medical
appointments it's only Korean and I that
I've held him right bud you're stuck
with us before Kovac we were looking
forward to a summer of having friends
and family business people like my mom
but unfortunately those plans got
cancelled yeah now everybody just have
to meet them through video chat which is
great but obviously not the same luckily
our friends have been amazing with gifts
and meals and socially distanced visits
so we're definitely lucky having a kid
is always going to be challenging but in
2020 with Co vid the black lives matter
protests and the growing concerns we've
already had over climate change there's
a lot going on in the old brain right
now
what's work and look like moving forward
where do we want to live who do we add
into our bubble we want to visit friends
and family but should we as a mix kid is
he gonna face some of the same
challenges I did growing up a visible
minority what kind of world are we gonna
leave him these are all some pretty big
questions and honestly sometimes can be
overwhelming but the time being we're
just taking it one day at a time
and trying to enjoy this crazy stage of
his life because we know it's gonna fly
by it's getting the snuggles enjoy all
the first and try to support
organizations and ideas the push things
forward in the end we all just want the
best for our kids and families
maybe 2020 is our pivot point we turn
things around I've always been pretty
motivated to do better now I have a
little more inspiration it's staring me
right in the face
[Music]